[Music]
uncle casey can't just stay for one
night
one night
[Music]
really
how big is he gonna get that depends on
how much you love him
clifford how did this happen
[Music]
that's the big red dog so cute
cuckoo cuckoo you know i'm a little
better why don't you take his
temperature where in the animal
temperature taking place
[Music]
it's all over the internet there's a
10-foot dog in upper manhattan that
can't be real we are offering a 25 000
reward for the capture of the big red
dog
people don't like things that are
different
there are no other dogs like you what's
he doing i think he's trying to be small
[Music]
what do we do we have to save him i'm in
what if you found someone who is so full
of love
he's sleeping
made me feel like you could do anything
your dog just saved my life
i'm getting clifford out of here you
know how to drive how hard can it be
i'm grounded for life aren't i you and
me both
he eats like an animal he is an animal
i'm talking about him
what
[Music]